The importance of Black History Month is very simple.
It's a time that we really need to reflect on the "where we've been" and "where we're going".
It's a journey that we have all taken...
...and we need to pass that on from generation to generation.
So with every generation, we have that lovely message and history to pass on.
And for those 28 days in February,...
...we really must take that time to really pass the message on...
...and pass the word of being proud of our heritage and where we've come from.
And what better way to do it than to celebrate in every facet possible?
Through poetry, through music, through dance, through theater.
It's a really special, special time,...
...and I'm so glad to be a part of it.
As the spokesperson this year, I'm very, very proud.